I like Kaitlyn because she's real and
she has both like a really fun silly
side and she's got some depth door and
then I really appreciate and find very
attractive oh so that's why he finds her
attractive her yeah nothing to do with
the bikini in the hot tub come on this
is Prince farming we're talking about
yeah that love this that is a scene for
next Monday's episode of The Bachelor
and we went behind the scenes of this
very unusual episode because Jimmy
Kimmel surprises everyone as a guest
host and Jimmy dares to go where Chris
Harrison never had oh you know just her
average bachelor makeout hot tub scene
and then this guy crashes the moment
good day guys
good girl my people I think wonder if
some of these things are prepared in
advance I'll tell you that this was he
had knowing he at least had no idea that
was gonna happen he's like yeah I'm here
I'm a big fan of the show I've watched
every episode and I'm here to help you
well this is perfect timing for the show
because ratings for this week's episode
we're down 23% and bachelor fanatics
like myself can't wait to see Kimmel
Corner Chris's latest aide Caitlyn the
Canadian dance instructor who's kinda
like this can pop out of my field
everything have you ever made out with a
woman
dad I have not oh I think these two like
each other I mean I love I'll be very
surprised if things go south with them I
mean there's there's definitely a
connection there and you know what I
want to say toast to your father
oh the poor bastard